Speaker 1: All right, so there was a hearing
yesterday, really over the last couple of
days and Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
was questioned by members of Congress, the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff, General
Mark Milley, was questioned.
And this hearing was the epitome of showboating
and grandstanding to no benefit whatsoever
of the American people.
Full stop.
There's barely more of that.
There's almost no additional analysis to do
other than many of these members of Congress
really have no business being in Congress.
And you'll very quickly figure out which individuals
those are.
Much of the hearing was meant to just provide
a cartoonish opportunity for people like Matt
Gates and others to demand and or request
that General Mark Milley resign.
And they couched it as being related to Afghanistan,
although the topic of Mark Milley having to
sort of reassure China that Trump is not going
to just bomb you in the last few days of his
presidency.
That's a story that we learned about as a
result of this book by Carol Leonnig and Philip
Rucker.
I believe it is.
Let's just get right into the clips.
It's really amazing.
Here is Congressman Joe Wilson, who calls
for President Joe Biden to resign.
Just countless calls for resignations during
these hearings.
Speaker 2: Buck stops with 13 murdered Marines.
Mr. Biden, the gentleman regarding the military
advice and I believe the president should
resign.
I'm prepared to begin my questions.
Speaker 1: I believe the president should
resign.
Everybody should resign.
According to these hearings then.
And this is actually really important.
Milley actually explains what it was that
led him to communicate with Chinese officials
in those final days of the Trump presidency.
And Congressman Hartzler, a Republican from
Missouri, says Milley should resign.
Look at this
Speaker 2: and others that the Chinese thought
wrongly that the United States is going to
attack them.
I am certain, guaranteed certain that President
Trump had no intent to attack.
And it was my task to make sure I communicated
that.
And the purpose was to de-escalate.
Speaker 3: I shared all that earlier.
I understand that to say.
Did you
Speaker 1: or did.
Sorry.
And I think I said Congressman Hartzler, it's
Congresswoman Hartzler.
I think I misspoke before
Speaker 3: to ask tell him that if we were
going to attack, you would let him know.
Speaker 2: As part of that conversation.
I said generally there's not going to be a
war, there's not going to be attack between
great powers.
And if there was, the tensions would build
up.
There'd be calls going back and forth from
all kinds of senior officials.
I said, help me up.
I give you a call, but we're not going to
attack you.
Trust me, we're not going to attack you.
These are two great powers, and I am doing
my best to transmit the president's intent.
Speaker 1: So understand that the right ones
to frame what Millie did as some kind of treason
by calling China and saying we're not going
to attack you no matter what.
Which then would be a signal to China, hey,
the U.S. isn't going to attack us no matter
what.
Now, it's a carte blanche for us to do stuff.
What Millie is explaining is he called and
he said, listen, in these last few days, Trump's
not going to just start dropping random bombs
on you.
If we were going to get into a military conflict,
there would be an escalation.
We would be talking the way that things happen.
There would be threats, there would be an
escalation.
That is obviously not the reason that the
right wants that wants to make it out to be.
But Hartzler doesn't care,
Speaker 2: intent to ensure that the American
people are protected from an incident that
could escalate.
Speaker 3: I understand your intent, but I
think you are articulating that that you would
tell him you would give him a call I think
is worthy of your resignation.
I just think that's against our country, that
you would give our number one adversary that
information and tell him that
Speaker 1: these people, they're either idiots
or they're pretending.
But there is it's there's just nothing there.
There's I don't know how else to say it.
Then Matt Gates gets involved and it gets
even more embarrassing.
Speaker 2: February twenty six, twenty twenty
House Armed Services Committee Gen. Mark Milley.
We know we're not going to defeat the Taliban
militarily and they're not going to defeat
the government of Afghanistan militarily.
You really blew that call, didn't you, General?
I believe that that was a issue of strategic
stalemate and that if we had remained in Afghanistan
with the advisory levels of effort, then the
government of Afghanistan.
That's that's an interesting answer to a question.
It's just not what I asked.
You spent more time with Bob Woodward on this
book than you spent analyzing the very likely
prospect that the Afghanistan government was
going to fall immediately to the Taliban,
didn't you?
Not even close.
Congressman.
Oh, really?
Because you said right after Kabul fell that
no one could have anticipated the immediate
fall of the Ghani government.
When did you become aware that Joe Biden tried
to get Ghani to lie about the conditions in
Afghanistan?
He did that in July.
Did you know that right away?
I'm not aware of what President Biden you're
not aware of the phone call that Biden had
with Ghani where he said whether it is true
or not, we want you to go out there and paint
a rosy picture of what's going on in Afghanistan.
You're the chief military adviser to the president.
You said that the Taliban was not going to
defeat the government of Afghanistan militarily,
which, by the way, they cut through them like
a hot knife through butter.
Speaker 1: It was just endlessly like this.
Just Gates is is horrible.
And then Gates mentions as an aside, that
Biden is too addled to even fire anyone, but
that they should be they shouldn't be in their
positions.
It just it gets crazy.
Speaker 2: But you said yesterday that you
are going to resign when senators asked you
this question.
And I believe that you guys probably won't
resign.
You seem to be very happy failing up over
there.
But if we didn't have a president that was
so addled, you all would be fired because
that is what you deserve.
You have let down the people who wear the
uniform in my district and all around this
country.
And you're far more interested in what your
perception is and how people think about you.
An insider Washington books than you care
about winning has been doing a Missoulian
is recognized.
Speaker 3: Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
And gentlemen, I apologize for the behavior
of my colleague.
Speaker 1: It's just grandstanding.
This this does nothing to move forward the
interests of the American people or of the
United States as a country globally.
In this next clip, Donald Trump's former doctor,
Ronnie Jackson, who's now a member of Congress,
also getting nearly completely exasperated.
Speaker 2: General Milley, will you now resign?
I serve at the pleasure of the president,
Mr. Jackson,
Speaker 1: Congressman Pat Fallin from Texas,
asking me about his comments about that horribly
botched drone strike in Afghanistan and of
course, taking them completely out of context.
Speaker 2: And General Milley, on September
1st, three days later, you described it as
a right to strike people that were not supposed
to be killed, were killed.
And you described it as a righteous strike.
You have to go back and look at the full quote.
What I said was we follow the procedures.
I had every reason to believe that that we
followed our procedures.
At that point in time, we knew that there
were civilians killed.
We knew they were noncombatants and there
was collateral damage, as you said, where
others killed.
Yes.
Were they?
We don't know.
We're trying to sort through all that, right?
That's exactly right.
That's right.
Because I believed kill people, which I believe
was right.
I believe that the target that we were aiming
at, sir, and I believe the target we were
aiming at was, OK, I have three more.
Speaker 1: And and this is a strategy which
is you don't even really give time to answer
the questions.
Now, I think I've already spoken about the
botched drone strike and it's absolutely horrifying
and disgusting.
But the idea that suddenly Republicans care
about drone strikes and civilian deaths is
laughable.
And then last clip here is the previous day.
This is Senator Tom Cotton again, bringing
up what why haven't there been resignations?
Speaker 2: One final question, General Milley.
I can only conclude that your advice about
staying in Afghanistan was rejected.
I'm shocked to learn that your advice wasn't
sought until August 25th on staying past the
August 31 deadline.
I understand that you're the principal military
adviser, but you advise you don't decide.
The president decides.
But if all this is true, General Milley, why
haven't you resigned, sir, as a senior military
officer, resigning is a really serious thing.
That's a political act if I'm resigning in
protest.
My job is to provide advice, my statutory
responsibilities, provide legal advice or
best military advice to the president.
And that's my legal requirement.
Speaker 1: That's so Milley having to explain
to Tom Cotton sort of like how things work.
We learned nothing from these hearings.
What is the dollar value, the dollar cost
of these hearings to just allow these Republicans
to ask, why haven't you resigned essentially
without an interest, even in learning anything
about what has actually taken place?
Just more pathetic behavior by this modern
Republican Party?